[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
SCOTT HUGHES: All right,
welcome to Tuesday.
So hopefully, you've all
saw the brief announcement
I send to the class.
I have to introduce a colloquium
speaker over in Astrophysics,
basically at the second
this class officially ends,
so I will be wrapping
things up a little bit
early so that I can take into
account the spatial separation
and get back there in time to
actually do the introduction.
I've already posted the
lecture notes of material
I'm going to be covering today,
and it'll probably spill--
I hope to wrap it all
up today, but it's
possible it'll spill a
little bit into Thursday.
So if you've already
looked at those notes,
today will essentially just
be sort of my guided tour
through that material.
So I want to pick it up with
where I left things last time.
So we covered a
bunch of material
that, again, I kind of emphasize
what we're doing right now
is just laying the mathematical
foundations in a very
thorough, almost excessively
thorough way in order
that we have a very strong
structure as we begin to move
into more physically
complicated situations
in the special relativity that
we're focusing on right now.
So we talked about
this definition
of an inner product between
two four-vectors, two vectors
in space time.
And it looks just like the inner
product between two vectors
that you are used to from
your Euclidean three space
intuition.
It's just that we have
an extra bit there
that enters with a
minus sign having
to do with the time like
components of those two
four-vectors.
And then, using the fact that
I can write my four vector
as components contracted onto
elements of a set of basis
vectors, I can use this
to define a tensor, which
I will get to the mathematical
definition of more
precisely in just a moment.
The dot product of
any two basis vectors,
I will call that the tensor
component, eta alpha beta.
OK, and so this is the metric
tensor of special relativity,
at least in rectilinear
coordinates.
Rectilinear basically just
means Cartesian but throwing
time in there as well.
OK, when we start talking
about special relativity
and curvilinear
coordinates, it'll
get a little bit more
complicated than that,
and I not use a symbol
eta in that case.
I am going to reserve eta
for this particular form
of the metric in this
coordinate system.
And of course, when you actually
write out these components,
a very compact way
of writing this is it
is just the matrix that has the
elements minus one, one, one,
one down the diagonal and
zeros everywhere else.
So this is a fairly common way
of writing a diagonal matrix.
This just takes into account
the fact that there's zeros
everywhere else.
So I call this
the metric tensor,
which kind of begs the
question, what's a tensor?
So this is where we
concluded things last time.
I'm going to generally
define a tensor of type 0n--
we're going to change that
zero to something else
by the end of today's lecture.
You'll be able to see where
I'm going probably from a mile
away, but let's just leave
it like this for now.
So a tensor of type 0n is--
you can think of it as
a function or a mapping
of n vectors into Lorentz
invariant scalars, which
is linear in its n arguments.
So the inner product clearly
falls into this category.
If I think of a dot b, let's
say this inner product is
some number, lowercase a.
A will be a Lorentz invariant.
I forgot to state
this, but the reason
we define the inner
product in this way
is that we are motivated by
the invariant interval in space
and time between two events.
We wanted to find an inner
product that duplicates
its mathematical structure.
If I take one of these vectors,
multiply it by some scalar,
linearity is going to hold.
This will just be
eta alpha beta.
This is terrible notation.
I'm using the [INAUDIBLE]
symbol alpha for both a pre
factor and an index.
Minus five points to me.
Let's call this gamma.
You can quickly
convince yourself.
That just comes out, and you
get a factor of gamma on this.
You can do the same
thing on the second slot.
If I take the dot product of a
with the sum of two vectors--
OK, et cetera.
You can keep going.
All the rules for linearity
are going to hold.
I'm not going to step
through them all.
You can see where they all go.
So whenever I'm going to
define a tensor, in my head,
I'm imagining it's got
properties like this
that come along for the ride.
Now, especially
when you see this
defined in certain
textbooks, MTW
is particularly
fond of doing this.
So we come back to this
idea that it's sort
of a function or a mapping.
You can almost abstractly
define the tensor
as a mathematical machine
that's got two slots in it.
So several of the
recommended textbooks
will write down equations.
I'm going to put two
lines over the symbol
to sort of-- if you actually
read this, in for instance, MTW
or Caroll or
something like that,
this will be written
as a boldface symbol.
It's hard to do
on the blackboard,
so I'm just going to
write double bars over it.
So if I imagine this with
my slots filled with these,
it's got two slots
associated with it.
I fill it with
those two vectors.
That is equivalent
to saying a dot b,
which is equivalent to it
in this component notation,
something like this.
So we have repeatedly
in the little bit
of time we've spent together--
I should say I have repeatedly,
in the little bit of time
we've spent together, emphasized
the distinction between frame
independent geometric
objects, things
that reside in the
manifold and have
kind of an integral, physical,
geometric sensibility
of their own and
their representations.
I have emphasized
quite strongly that you
should think of
the vectors a and b
as being geometric objects.
This is some thing that
is pointing in space time.
We all agree that
this points, if that's
a displacement vector, it points
from event one to event two.
OK, everyone agrees on that
geometric reality of this.
Different observers
may represent
it using different components.
That's just because
they're using
different coordinate systems.
So when I write down
something like this--
so let's go back to
where I wrote before.
This is going to turn into
some frame independent Lorentz
scalar a.
So this is what I like to call
a frame independent object.
Frame or Lorentz
independent geometric
object, as is this scalar.
And so therefore, the
tensor must be a frame
independent geometric
object as well.
That's a lot of words
around the blackboard,
but I really want to
nail that point home.
So tensors just like vectors.
Think of them as
geometric objects
that have an intrinsic geometric
meaning associated with them
that lives in spacetime.
We will talk about
certain examples of them.
OK, you guys all have some
intuition about vectors,
because you've
been doing vectors
ever since you took your first
kindergarten physics course,
and so you know that there's
some kind of an object that
points in a certain direction.
Tensors are a little bit more
challenging in many cases
to develop an intuition for.
Some of them really do
have a fairly simple
geometric interpretation.
You can kind of
think of them as--
for instance, we're going to
introduce one a little bit,
which describes the flow
of energy and momentum
in space time.
And so it'll have two
indices associated with it,
and those indices
tell me about what
component of energy
or momentum is flowing
in a particular direction.
Really easy to interpret that.
Some of the others, not so much.
Nonetheless, they do have
this geometric meaning
underneath the hood.
And that's bound up
in the fact that if I
put frame independent geometric
objects into all the slots,
I get a Lorentz invariant
number out of it.
It's the only way that
that can sort of work.
But one reason why
I'm going through this
is that just like with
vectors, different observers,
different frames will
get different components
in general.
So there will be different
representations according
to different observers.
I'm going to write
down the same thing.
Representations.
So if you want to get
a particular observer's
components out of
the tensor, there's
actually a very simple
recipe for this.
All you do is, you take your
tensor, and into its slots,
you plug in the basis vectors
that that observer uses.
So if I want to get
the components--
and this, unfortunately,
is a fairly stupid example,
but it's the only one we've
got at the moment, so let's
just work with it.
If I take the tensor eta, the
special relativity metric,
I plug in some
observer's basis factors
into this thing, this by
definition is eta alpha beta.
Suppose I have a different
observer who comes along,
someone who-- we're
doing special relativity,
so someone who's dashing
through the room at three
quarters of the speed of light.
I want to know what their
components would be.
Well, what I do is, I
just plug into the slots--
let's put bars on
the complements
to denote this other observer.
Do this operation for this other
observers set of basis vectors,
and you will get the components
that they will measure.
Now, one of the reasons
why I'm going through this
is that last time,
we talked about how
to transform basis vectors
between different reference
frames.
We know that these guys are
just related to one another
by a Lorentz
transformation matrix.
So let's just take
this a step further.
So this is telling me
that the components
of the metric in
this barred frame,
they're going to be what I get
when I put it into the slots.
Those are the basis vectors
in the barred frame using
the Lorentz
transformation matrix
to go from the unbarred
frame to the barred frame.
Now, remember again-- this
is one of those places where
if you're sort of just becoming
comfortable with the index
notation, you're temptation
at this stage is always to go,
these are matrices.
I should start doing
matrix multiplication.
If you set that urge within you
aside, you go, no, no, no, no.
Those are just a
set of 16 numbers.
For any particular
set of complements,
I can just pull them out.
So because of the linearity
of all these slots
with this thing, this just
becomes those two Lorentz
transformation matrices acting
on the abstract metric tensor
with the unbarred basis
vectors in the slots.
And this we already know.
This is, by definition,
this is just eta mu nu.
Repeat this exercise
for any tensor
you care to write down, any 0n
tensor you care to write down.
Go through all
this manipulation,
and you will always find that
there's a very simple algorithm
forgetting the
components in, let's
call it the barred
observers frame,
as converted from the
unbarred observers frame.
Essentially, you just hit
it with a bunch of Lorentz
transform matrices, and as
an old professor of mine
liked to say at this
point, line up the indices.
That's really all
we're doing, is
we're just going
to line up the mus
to convert them to alpha bars.
Alpha bar here, mu
there, put this guy here.
I want to convert my
new into a beta bar.
I put my matrix there.
Boom.
Just line up the
indices, and we're done.
Now, this is, as I
kind of emphasized,
a fairly stupid
example, because if you
take the diagonal of
minus one, one, one, one
and you apply the most
God awful immense Lorentz
transformation you care
to write down to it,
you do all the
matrix manipulation
and you line it all up,
what you'll end up finding
is that this is the diagonal
of minus one, one, one, one
in all frames.
That's actually one of the
defining characteristics
of the metric of
special relativity.
If you're working
curvilinear coordinates,
the metric is always minus one,
one, one, one to all observers.
So the recipe holds in general.
This will hold whenever
we are studying tensors
from now and from henceforth.
Just so happens that this
first example we were given
is kind of a dumb one.
Nonetheless, learn the lesson
and overlook the example,
and wisdom shall be yours.
I want to spend a
few moments talking
about a particular subset of
tensors, of the 0n tensors,
where n equals one.
This is a subset of
tensions in general
that is known in many
textbooks as one forms.
For reasons that I will
elaborate on in probably
10 or so minutes, these are also
sometimes called dual vectors.
And just if that's sort of
making some neurons light up
in your head, set that
aside for a moment.
I want to carefully
go through them
before I indicate the manner in
which there is a duality that
is being applied here.
So if we go back to the
definition of a tensor,
this tells us that a
one form is a mapping
from a single vector to the
Lorentz invariant scalar.
So using some notation
that I will probably only
use in this lecture,
because we're
going to move past this
notation pretty soon,
let's say a one form--
I'm going to denote this
with an over tilde on it.
So let's say p is a one form.
It will have in this
sort of abstract notation
a single slot, so I put
the vector a into it.
And this then gives
me some scalar out.
So in my notes, I go through
some stuff indicating
that this guy is-- it's
a linear operation,
but that's obvious, because
it just inherits all
the properties from
tensors, so I'm not
going to go through that.
If you want to double
check some of the details,
they're in the notes
that have been posted.
Just like with the
tensors, I extract
components from this thing
by putting my basis vectors
inside.
So if I take my one form p
and I put it in my alpha basis
vector, this gives me the alpha
component of the one form.
Notice, it's in the
downstairs position.
So one of the reasons why I
want to go through this step
is it gives me a way
to think about what's
going on at this scalar that
I wrote down on the top board
here.
So what is this scalar
that I get by putting
a vector into my one form?
So I take this, put
my vector in here.
I use the fact that
I can write my vector
using its components
and the basis vector.
I use linearity to
pull this guy out.
So the scalar that
I get by doing this
is just the scalar that one
gets by contracting the upstairs
components that I use
to set up my vector
with the downstairs components
I use to set up my one form.
This is an operation that is
called contraction, for reasons
that I hope are fairly obvious.
So let me define a few other
characteristics of this thing,
and in just a few moments,
we'll see what this is good for.
OK, so one of things
I'm going to want to do
is change the representation
of those things.
So I'm going to want to know
how these components transform
between different
frames of reference.
But we've already done that.
We did this using tensors,
and this is just a tensor.
So if I change
reference frames, if I
want to know what the
components are according
to some barred
observer, I will step
through the algebra
in my notes, but I
think you know where I'm
going to go with this.
You just take the components
in the unbarred frame,
line it up, contract it with
the correct setup of my Lorentz
transformation matrix, boom.
Line at the indices,
and we've got it there.
So the last thing which I want
to do with this before I talk
a little bit about what this
is really good for is say,
you know, I've got
these basis vectors that
allow me to relate the
components of my vectors
to the geometric object
in a way where I don't
use a represented bi-symbol.
I actually have an
honest to God equal sign.
Can I define a similar
set of basis one forms?
What I want to do is define a
family of geometric objects,
and I will denote them with
an omega and a tilde such
that any one form can be written
as its components attached
to these little basis vectors.
Well, the way I'm
going to do this
is, I'm going to exploit
the fact that I already
know what basis vectors are.
So I know, for instance,
that if I take my one form
and I plug in a basis
factor, I get this.
And so what I want to
do is combine this thing
which I would like to
do with the defining
operation of contractions.
So I know p alpha
a alpha is what
I get when I've got my one
form and I plug into its slot
the vector a.
OK, so let's insist
that when I do this,
I can write this as
p beta omega beta.
Now remember, these
are the components.
This is the actual
basis one form.
So I'm going to stick
into my basis one form
this form of the vector.
I can then use the linearity
of the tensor nature
to pull out that component of a.
So what this tells me is
this is exactly what I want,
provided whatever this
geometric object is,
it obeys the rule that when
I plug basis vectors into it,
I get the Kronecker delta back.
Now, this may all seem really,
really trivial right now.
And indeed, if you
think about this,
in terms of just running
down mathematical symbols,
this is fairly trivial.
One thing which I
want to emphasize
is that if you go
through and say, well,
if I'm working in
a basis where this
has a time-like component
that I'll say is one,
the time-like direction
is zero everywhere else.
Remember to set the
points in the x direction,
so it's zero, one along
x, zero everywhere else.
This then leads to--
so as an example, a
set of basis objects
that a particular observer
would write just like so.
I won't write out the
two and three components.
And again, you look at this and
you think to yourself, dude,
you're just repeating
basis vectors.
What's the big deal here?
Now, I'm going to explain the
fact that these are sometimes
called dual vectors.
So if we want to think about
this in a language that
is reminiscent of
linear algebra,
if you think of the basis
vectors as column vectors,
then my basis one forms are
essentially row vectors.
So these look a lot
like my basis vectors.
They enter in a dual way.
And so they're going to
play an important role
in helping us to--
whenever I contract
two objects together
to make some kind of a
Lorentz invariant scalar,
I'm going to want to
only combine objects
that have a dual nature like.
That's the only way I can get
something sensible out of it.
So let me give you an example.
Mathematically, this is an
equation that I can write down.
No question.
If I'm in a
particular frame, I've
got the components
of vector a, I've
got the complements
of vector b, I
can multiply their complements
together, sum them,
and square them.
So this is mathematically
well-defined but plays no role
in the physics we are going
to talk about this term,
because this is not related
to the underlying invariant
structure of the manifold
that we are working with.
So remember I talked about
how a manifold is essentially
a sufficiently smooth set of
points endowed with a metric?
Well, the metric is what tells
us that this is mathematically
short.
Write it down, but
it means nothing.
By contrast, of course this
has frame independent meaning.
This is important.
So that's the sense in which
these one forms are often
called duels actors.
It is when they are
combined with vectors,
they are duel to it in the
sense that when they're
combined in this
appropriate way,
we find that they
describe the physics,
they capture the
invariant characteristics
of the physics that are
important in the theory
that we are describing.
If I may give one
more example that
is from a completely
different field
but I think helps to sort of
illustrate a useful analogy
to think about these
things, suppose
you are doing quantum
mechanics and I give you
two wave functions.
So suppose you have
a wave function
psi of x and another
wave function phi of x.
If you wanted to, you could
multiply them together
and integrate overall space.
I don't know what you would
do with that, but you could.
On the other hand, you could
take the complex conjugate
of one of them, multiply
it by the other one,
multiply it overall
space, and in the notation
that you learn about,
this is, of course,
just the inner product of wave
function psi with wave function
phi.
Forming the one
form, using a one
form is akin to selecting
an object that has--
it allows us to make a
mathematical construction
similar to the quantum
mechanical enterprise
that we use here.
And as we'll see in just
a couple of minutes,
it's actually really easy
to flip back and forth
between one forms and vectors.
OK, so a better
way to move forward
with this is rather
than talking in terms
of these more abstract things,
let me you a good example.
So imagine I have some
trajectory through spacetime.
So let's let the t axis go up.
There's my x and y-axes.
You all can imagine the z-axis.
And some observer moves
through spacetime like so.
Last lecture, we
talked about a couple
of important examples
of four-vectors.
And so one which is
germane to the situation
is the four velocity
of this observer.
That just expresses
the rate of change
of its position in spacetime
per unit proper time.
And I'll remind
you, tau is time as
measured along this
observer's trajectory.
So roughly speaking, not
even roughly speaking,
exactly speaking,
tau is the time
that is measured by the by
the watch of the person moving
along there.
So suppose in addition to this
person sort of trundling along
through spacetime
here, suppose spacetime
is filled with some field,
phi, which depends on all
of my spacetime coordinates.
Question I want
to ask is, what is
the rate of change of phi along
this observer's trajectory?
So if you are working in
ordinary Euclidean space,
you would basically
say, ah, this is easy.
So you're three space intuition.
You don't have this proper
time to worry about.
So you would just say that d
phi dt along this trajectory
is just what I get
when I calculate dx dt.
And then look at
the x derivative
of my field phi plus dy dt.
This is one of
those places where
getting the difference
between a partial
and a total derivative
right is important.
So if you see me do that
again, if I don't correct it,
yell at me.
OK, so you get this.
And then you say, ah,
this is nothing more
than that particle's
velocity dotted
into the gradient
of the field phi.
It's a directional
derivative along the velocity
of this trajectory.
So generalizing
this to spacetime,
you basically have the
same thing going on.
Only now, time is a coordinate.
So we don't treat time as
the independent parameter
that describes the ticking
of clocks as I move along it.
I use the proper
time of the observer
as my independent parameter.
So what I will say
is, the rate at which
the field changes per
unit of this guy's
proper time, every one of these
is a component of the four
velocity.
So now, we introduce a
little bit of notation.
So this derivative is what I
get when I contract the four
velocity against a quantity
that's defined by taking
the derivative of this field.
We're going to be taking
derivatives like this a lot,
so a little bit of
notation being introduced
to save us some writing.
This is the directional
derivative along the trajectory
of this body.
Now, this is a frame
independent scalar.
This is a quality that all
observers will agree on.
This is a four velocity.
We know this is a four velocity.
These are the components
of a four-vector,
so these are the
components of a one form.
So the generalization
of a gradient
is an example of a one form.
So re-using that abstract
notation that I gave earlier,
I can write-- so the way
you will sometimes see this
is, the abstract gradient
one form of the field phi
is represented by the
components, the alpha phi.
You will also in some cases--
and I actually have a few
lines about this in my notes--
sometimes, people will recycle
the notation of a gradient
that you guys learn about
in undergraduate E&M.
I urge a little bit of
caution with this notation,
because we are going to use
this symbol for a derivative
to mean something a
little bit different
in just a couple of lectures.
It turns out that the
something different reduces
to this in the special
relativity limit,
so there's no harm being done.
But just bear in mind
this particular notion
of a derivative here is
going to change its meaning
in a little bit.
Another little bit of notation
that is sometimes used here,
and this is one
more unfortunately,
I think I'm stuck with this
notation, one often says--
so this idea of
taking a derivative
along a particular four
velocity, it comes up a lot.
So sometimes, what
people then do
is, they define it as
the directional gradient
along u of the field phi.
So don't worry
about this too much.
We'll come back to us a
little bit more appropriate.
I just want you to
be aware, especially
for those of you who
might be reading ahead,
when you see this.
So just think of this as
what you get when I am taking
a gradient along a velocity u.
It basically refers to the
gradient one form contracted
with the four-vector u.
So the last thing I want
to do as I talk about this
is revisit this
notion of one forms
as being dual to vectors
for just a moment.
So we've just
introduced the gradient
as our first example
of a one form.
So the notion of the
gradient as a one form, this
gives us a nice way to think
about what the basis one
forms mean.
So when I introduced basis
one forms a few moments ago,
it was a purely
mathematical definition.
I just wanted to
have objects such
that when I popped
in the basis vectors,
I got the Kronecker delta back.
And after belaboring
the obvious, perhaps
for a little bit too
long, we essentially
got a bunch of ones
and zeros out of it.
Now, putting in math
all of those words,
I did a lot of junk to get that.
But we also know
that if I just take
the derivative of my
coordinate with my coordinate,
I'm going to get the
Kronecker deltas.
This and this, these
are the same thing.
So I can think of this
operation here as telling me
if I regard this as this kind
of abstract form of the gradient
applied to the
coordinate itself,
this is nothing more
than my basis one form.
So my basis one forms are
kind of like gradients
of my coordinates.
OK, you're sitting
here thinking, OK,
what the hell does this
have to do with anything?
So when we combine--
set that aside for
just a second--
and remind you of some
pretty important intuition
that you probably learned
the very first time
you learned about the gradient.
So imagine I just draw level
surfaces of some function in--
I'll just do two
dimensional space.
OK, so I have some
function h of x and y.
This represents, like for
instance, a height field.
If I'm looking at
a topographic map,
this might tell me about
where things are high
and where things are low.
So h of xy, there might be
level surfaces on my map.
It'd kind of look like this.
And there'd be another one
that kind of looks like this.
And maybe it'd have
something like this,
and then something
kind of right here.
So we know looking at this
thing that the gradient is very
low here and very high here.
Let's put this into
the language of what
we are looking at right now.
OK, let's let delta x be a
displacement vector in the xy
plane, and dh is going to be
my one form of my [] function.
How do I get the
change in height
as I move along my
displacement vector?
Well, take my one form,
plop into its slot delta x,
I get something like this.
The thing which I kind
of want to emphasize here
is, we have a lot of geometric
intuition about vectors.
So if I have a delta x--
let' say this is my delta x.
It lasts for about
this long over here.
I take the exact same delta
x, and I apply it over here.
I get a very different
result, because that
goes through many more
contours on the left side
than it does on the right side.
And the thing-- this is where
this duality kind of comes
in, and I'm going to put up a
couple of graphics illustrating
this here--
is that you should
think of the one form
as essentially that
set of level surfaces.
It's a little confusing.
I'm not going to--
I mean, I can see a
couple blank looks.
Maybe even the
majority of you have
kind of blank looks
on your faces here.
And that's fine.
So what I want you to
regard is that when
I'm talking about
basis one forms
and one forms of functions,
they have a very different
geometric interpretation, even
though you're kind of used
to gradient as
telling you something
about the direction along
which something is changing.
Actually, you define
that direction.
The thing that
you're worried about
is sort of how close
the different level
surfaces are of things.
OK, so coming back to this
idea that my basis one form
that I use are essentially
just the gradients
of the coordinates.
So I'm going to put
some graphics up
on the website,
which I have actually
scanned out of the textbook by
Misner, Thorne, and Wheeler.
And what they basically
show is, let's
say this is the time direction.
Let's say this is my x-axis.
And this is my y-axis.
Your intuition is
that the x basis
vector will be a little
arrow pointing along x.
Well, what your intuition
should be like for the x basis
one form is a series of sheets
normal to the x-axis that
fill all of space.
OK, spaced one
unit apart, filling
all of space kind of like that.
So here's one example
of one of those sheets.
And notice, the x-axis pierces
every one of those things.
That's another
way in which these
are sort of a set
of dual functions
to the vectors themselves.
This notion-- so
I'm going to turn
to something which is
perhaps a little less
weird in about 30 seconds.
But the one thing
which I kind of
want to emphasize with
this-- and again, I'm
going to put a couple
graphics up that
help to illustrate this.
And there's some really
nice discussions of this.
MTW is particularly good
for this discussion.
This ends up being a
really useful notion
for capturing how we are
going to compute fluxes
through particular directions.
Because if I want to know
the flux of something
in the x direction,
well, my x basis one form
is actually like a sheet
that captures everything
that flows in the x direction.
So it's sort of a
mathematical object that's
designed for catching fluxes.
If isn't quite gelling
with you, that's fine.
This is without a doubt
one of the goofier things
we're going to talk about in
this first introductory period
of stuff.
This is one of
those places where
I think it's sort of
fair to say, if you're
not quite getting
what's going on,
shut up and calculate
works well enough.
It's kind of like you know the
Feynman's mantra on quantum
mechanics.
Sometimes, you've just
got to say, OK, whatever.
Learn the way it
goes, and it's kind
of like playing a
musical instrument.
You sort of strum it and
practice it for a while,
and it becomes second
nature after a while.
All right, so to
wrap this up, what
I want to do for the last
major thing today is,
I hope I can kind of put a bow
on our discussion of tensors.
Let's come back to the metric
as our original example
of a tensor here.
So when I give you the
metric as an abstract tensor,
and I imagine I have
filled both slots,
I get a Lorentz
invariant number.
A dot b is what I get
when I take this tensor
and I put a and b into it slots.
Suppose I only fill
one of its slots.
Well, if I take this,
I plug in the vector
a but I leave the other slot
blank, well, what I've got
is a mathematical object
that will take a vector
and produce a Lorentz
invariance number.
That's a one form.
So let's do this very carefully
and abstractly for a moment.
But at this point, we basically
have almost all the pieces
in place.
And so I'm going to kind of
tone down some of the formality
fairly soon.
So let's define a one
form, an object that
takes a single
vector inside of it
as what I get when
I take the metric
and put that vector in there.
If I want to get
its components out,
well, I know the way I do
that is I put the basis
vector in there.
This guy is symmetric, so I can
flip the order of the metric.
It's symmetric, so I can
flip the order of these guys.
And what this tells me is that
my one form component of a
is just the vector
component of a hit
by the components of the metric.
In other words, the metric
converts vectors into one forms
by lowering the indices.
This is an invertebrate
procedure as well.
So this metric, I can define
eta with indices in the upstairs
position by requiring that
eta alpha beta contracted
with it in the
downstairs position
gives me the identity back.
Incidentally, when
you do this, you again
find it's got exactly the
same matrix representation.
So this thing with its indices
in the upstairs position
is just minus one,
one, one, one.
It will not always
be that way, though.
Again, this is just
because special relativity
in rectilinear
coordinates is simple.
So I will often call
that the inverse metric.
And then, you
shouldn't have a lot
of trouble convincing yourself
that if I've got a one form,
I can make a vector out of it
by a contraction operation.
That now tells me that I have
about 16 gagillian-- well,
actually, it's a countable
and finite thing.
But I have many ways that I can
write down the inner product
between two vectors.
This guy is-- if you
like, you can now
regard a vector as being
a sort of a function
that you put one forms into.
These are all the same.
These are all equivalents
to one another.
And actually making
a distinction
between vector in one
form and all that,
it's just kind of gotten
stupid at this point.
So the distinction among
these different objects,
the different names,
kind of doesn't matter.
And indeed, you sort
of look at this.
Up until now, we've
regarded tensors
as being these sort of things
that operate on vectors.
OK, but why not regard
vectors as things
that operate on one forms?
What this sort of tells you
is that this whole notion
of tensors being separate
from vectors that I talked
about before is kind of silly.
So I'm going to revisit
the definition of a tensor
that I started the
lecture off with like so.
So a new and more
complete definition.
A tensor of type mn is a linear
mapping of m1 forms and n
vectors to the Lorentz scalars.
In this definition-- so we've
already introduced zero,
one tensors.
Those are one forms.
One zero tensors are vectors.
Furthermore, as I
kind of emphasized
when I wrote this sentence
here, the distinction
between the slots that operate
on vectors and the slots that
operate on one forms,
it's nice for getting some
of the basic foundations laid.
This is one of
those places where
now that the scaffolding
is in place--
we've had the scaffolding
in place for a while,
but this wall of our
edifice is pretty steady,
so we can kick the
scaffolding away.
We can sort of lose
this distinction.
The metric lets us
convert the nature
of the slots on a tensor.
So if I have an mn tensor and
I use the metric to lower,
that means I make it an m
minus one n plus one tensor.
So an example would
be, if I have a tensor
r mu beta gamma delta and
I lower that first index,
so this went from something
that operates on one,
one form and three vectors.
Now, it's one it
operates on four-vectors.
Likewise using the inverse
metric, you can raise--
and just for completeness,
let's write that out.
So an example of this would be
if I have some tensor su beta
gamma, and let's say I
raised that first index
to get something like this.
OK, so let's see.
In my last couple
of minutes-- recall,
I do have to leave a little
bit early today, because I
need to introduce a speaker.
But I just want to wrap up
one thing kind of quickly.
I've spent a bunch of time
talking about basis objects.
And I'm going to go through
this fairly quickly.
The notes, if you want to
see a few more details,
you're welcome to
download and look at them.
They're not really
tricky or super critical.
We know we have basis
objects for vectors,
which hopefully you have
pretty good intuition about.
We have basis objects for one
forms, where your intuition is
perhaps a little
bit more befuddled,
but it'll come with time.
So you might think, uh, now
I've got two index tenors.
I've got three index tensors.
There's a four index
tensor on the board.
Scott's probably going
to write 17 index tensor
on the board at some point.
Do I need a basis object
for every one of those?
So in other words, do we need--
glad that's caught on video--
do I need to be able
to say something
like the abstract
metric tensor is
these components times some kind
of a two index basis object?
Do I need to do
something like this?
Cutting to the chase,
the answer is no.
Basis one forms and
vectors are sufficient.
So what we're going
to do is, abstractly
just imagine that if
I do have a tensor,
I kind of have an outer product.
I have both of the basis
objects attached to this thing,
and each one is just
attached to those two slots.
OK, so in this particular case,
my two index basis two-form
that would go with
this thing here,
the thing with
two indices on it,
I'm just going to
regard this as--
I'll abstractly write this
as just an outer product
on the basis one forms.
If I ever need a basis object
for a tensor like this,
I will just regard this as
an outer product of these two
things.
So what's going on
with that notation?
What does this mean?
Don't lose too much
sleep about it.
It's basically saying that I
have separate objects attached
to all of my different
indices, and they're
kind of coming along here and
giving a sense of direction
to these things.
So for instance, if I have
some kind of a tensor--
I mean, a great one, which
we're going to talk about
in just a little bit.
It's a quantity known
as the stress energy
tensor, in which
I can abstractly
think of the tensor as having--
not just a [INAUDIBLE].
It will have two components.
And I can think of
it as essentially
pointing in two different
directions at once.
Now, we're going to talk about
this in a lot more detail
in a couple of weeks.
Actually, not even
a couple of weeks.
A couple of lectures.
What I'm going to teach you is
that the alpha beta component
of the stress energy
tensor tells me
about the flux of form
momentum component alpha
in the beta direction.
And so this is
basically just saying,
when I think of it as
the actual object, not
just the representation
according to some observer,
here is the thing that gives
me the direction of my four
momentum, and here
is the direction
in which it is flowing.
And sometimes, we will make
more complicated objects.
And so you might
need to imagine--
here's one which I actually
wrote down in my notes here--
there will be times
when we're going
to care about a tensor which at
least abstractly, we might need
to regard as having this whole
set of sort of vomitous basis
vectors coming along
for the ride here.
And it is actually
fairly important
to have all these things
that are in place.
Where I will just
conclude things
for today is that the place
where it is particularly
important to remember that we
kind of sometimes almost just
implicitly have these
things coming along
for the ride here--
it's important when we
calculate derivatives.
So I gave you guys an example
of a directional derivative
for a scalar field that
filled all its spacetime.
I imagine that there was some
trajectory of an observer
moving through this.
Now, imagine it isn't a scalar
field that fills all of,
spacetime but it's
a tensor field.
Here's t.
We'll say this is
the y direction.
This is the x direction.
Here's my observer moving
through all this thing.
And again, I'm going to
say that this trajectory is
characterized by a
four velocity, dxt tau,
and I'm going to imagine that
there is some tensor field that
fills all of spacetime
when I go and calculate
the derivative of
this thing, when
we're working in
special relativity
where we are right now, these
guys are going to be constant,
so it doesn't really matter.
But soon, we're
going to generalize
to more complicated geometries,
more complicated spacetimes,
and the basis objects
will themselves
vary as I move along
the trajectory.
And I will need to--
in order to have
a notion of a derivative
that is a properly
formed geometric
object, I'm going
to have to worry about how the
basis objects change as I move
along this trajectory as well.
So that tends to just
make the analysis
a little bit more complicated.
I have a few notes about
this that I will put up
on to the web page, but I don't
want to go into too much detail
beyond that until
we actually get
into some of the details
of these derivatives.
So I'm just going to
leave it at that for now.
So yeah, I'll just say,
the derivative in principle
and quite often in
practice, it will
depend on how these guys
vary in space and time.
And let me just say, you guys
kind of already know that.
Because when you
studied E&M, you
got these somewhat
complicated formulas
for things like the divergence
and curl and stuff like that.
And those are
essential, because those
are notions of derivative
where you are taking
into account the fact that
when you're in a curvilinear
coordinate system, your basis
vectors are shifting as you
move from point to point.
The stuff we're
going to get out this
will look a little
bit different,
and it comes to the fact, as I
emphasized in my last lecture,
that we are going to
tend to use what we call
a coordinate basis, whereas when
you guys learn stuff in E&M,
you were using what's known
as an orthonormal basis.
And it does lead to
slight differences.
There's a mapping between them.
Not that hard to
figure it out, but we
don't need to get into
those weeds just now.
All right, so I will pick it
up from there on Thursday.
So I'll begin with a brief
recap of everything we did.
The primary thing which I
really want to emphasize more
than anything is this
board plus this idea
that the metric can be
used to raise and lower
the indices of a tensor.
At this point,
talking about vectors,
talking about one forms,
many of you in a math class
probably learned about
contravariant vector components
and covariant vector components.
Once you've got a metric,
it's kind of like, who cares?
You can just go from
one to the other.
And that's why I tend
to, almost religiously, I
avoid the terms covariant
and contravariant,
and I just say,
upstairs and downstairs.
Because I can flip back
and forth between them,
and there's really no
physical meaning in them.
You have to think
carefully about what
is physically
measurable, and it has
nothing to do with whether
it's covariant or convariant,
upstairs or downstairs.
All right, I will end
there, since I have
to go and introduce someone.